- You have to remember,
District 14 is made up
of a lot of immigrants,
a lot, legal immigrants.
They came from socialism.
They don't want it.
They know what it's about.
They're disgusted.
And what's going on with
the crime, outta control.
AOC wrote that letter
a few years ago
stating that police in
our subways is racist.
Look at our subways.
Look at the subways.
They don't want that.
They have to close
their businesses early.
They came here for
the American dream
and the American
dream is being ripped
from everyone in
the 14th District.
Even across the country,
we're being controlled by...
Okay, you have the Democrats
in the House, Senate,
and the presidency.
They're destroying our
country, but the 14th District
is really taking a very
hard hit because of AOC.
(resonating music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the Republican
candidate for Congress
in New York's 14th District
running against AOC.
Tina Forte, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you for having me.
How are you?
- I'm doing well, Tina.
I said to you right
before we started,
we talked for about 10 seconds,
man, on accent alone,
I want you in Congress.
You are like New
York all over ya.
- Well, born and raised in
the Bronx, in the district.
- Actually in the
district, right?
- Actually in the district.
- Like, actually in the
district that
you're running for?
- Yes, I was born and raised
in the Bronx, in Throgs Neck.
Went to St. Francis de Chantal,
graduated Preston High School.
My first job was
in the district,
got married in the district,
raised my kids in the district,
I have a business
in the district.
I am the district. (chuckles)
- So I sense that
you did not think
that politics was
in your future,
but perhaps AOC
dragged you to this.
Is that fair to say?
- Yes.
Everything dragged me
to this, but more so AOC
because she is
representing my district.
I'm not a politician.
I'm a mother, grandmother,
small business owner,
and after COVID,
I just had enough.
I started ranting in my car,
started building
momentum and a following,
and I just was
speaking for people.
And I was going to
rallies and protests.
I stood with business
owners during the lockdowns.
I spoke up for our children
in school with the mandates.
I spoke up for our city workers.
I backed the blue.
I was down in the city
with the law and order,
the big beautiful flags I
would walk in the streets with.
And I just became very vocal
and I'm fighting for the people
and I want my voice
to be for the people.
- Yeah, speaking of your voice,
I can tell you've been you've
been out there screaming, huh?
It's tough giving
speeches every day.
- Yes, I am.
I'm talking every day.
I do have COVID damage, so
that has a lot to do with it
'cause I did almost
die from COVID.
- Wow.
- And I have esophagus damage
so it weakens my voice.
- Wow, well, you're-
- That's okay. I'm strong.
Forte, strong and loud.
- (laughs) As I said to you
right before we started,
we could use some more
Italian mamas in Congress.
I think that really could-
- Yes.
- Could fix this whole thing up.
What can you tell me
about the 14th District,
where obviously, you're from
and business as you said
and grandma there
and all that stuff?
Because I think people
don't really have
any understanding of
the district other than
somehow AOC magically
appeared in this place
and now she's on the front page
of everything all the time.
- You have to remember,
District 14 is made up
of a lot of immigrants,
a lot, legal immigrants.
They came from socialism.
They don't want it.
They know what it's about.
They're disgusted.
And what's going on with
the crime, outta control.
AOC wrote that letter
a few years ago
stating that police in
our subways is racist.
Look at our subways.
Look at the subways.
They don't want that.
They have to close
their businesses early.
They came here for
the American dream
and the American
dream is being ripped
from everyone in
the 14th District.
Even across the country
we're being controlled by...
Okay, you have the Democrats
in the House, Senate,
and the presidency.
They're destroying our
country, but the 14th District
is really taking a very
hard hit because of AOC.
She's not here to
represent the people,
and when she goes
to a town hall,
the people go
there, they listen,
they wanna hear
what she has to say,
if she's gonna back the blue.
No, they sat there for an hour.
An hour.
They were very respectful.
They listened to her and as
soon as the first man stood up
and asked her about crime,
she would not answer
and the crowd got angry.
And she danced and
she mocked them
and she was condescending
and she was rude,
and that was a disgrace.
And as a congresswoman, you
have to represent the district
on both sides, left and right.
You have to be their voice.
You have to listen to them.
You don't hat to
agree with them.
So what she did to
me was disgusting.
And she won't debate me.
I've been calling her out.
I show up to her town halls.
I'm outside with a microphone.
I sent a chicken to her office,
a live chicken with a sign
that says "AOC's a
chicken. Debate me."
Oh, yeah.
- (laughs) Where's
that chicken now?
- The chicken's following
her all over the district.
She actually ran
off to California.
She said in her first town hall
in Columbus High
School in the Bronx
that she was not leaving
the district at all.
She would be in the district
up until the election.
Well, she ran to
California, and guess what?
She got heckled there.
She can run, but she can't hide.
- When you saw her come down
to my state during COVID
as she had you guys
locked down and masked up
and she was, you know forcing
people to get vaccinated
and everything else, and
then she was drinking,
I think margaritas,
down on South Beach,
I'm guessing that
didn't go over too well
in the Bronx.
- No, she's a hypocrite.
No, she's a hypocrite.
Same thing when she
goes to her town halls.
She walks in with security.
The NYPD's outside with
the cars and the sirens on,
yet she defunds them.
She's a hypocrite.
And I think everyone now
sees her for what she is.
Like I says, she is a candidate,
a congresswoman from Wish.
That's what I call her, the
congresswoman from Wish.
- Yeah.
- They got her
and now they see that
she's ineffective
and they want a refund.
- Do you think that people,
not only because
they're seeing the crime
and then all the COVID
stuff and all that,
like the stuff that's
obviously on the ground there,
but also that she has just tried
to be a political
star this whole time,
where you never hear her
talking about her district,
actually ever.
I mean-
- No, she doesn't.
- She's on every
show every weekend,
you know, treated
with kid gloves.
- Right.
- But I never hear her
talking about the Bronx.
- Nope, she doesn't.
- She's trying to be
a national star.
- Well, she used the district
to push her radical left agenda.
She auditioned for the part.
Remember, she did
have an audition.
- Literally auditioned
for the part, yeah.
- Yeah, she literally
auditioned for the part,
and she used the district
to push her agenda.
I call her AOC,
All Out Communist.
That's what she is.
She's the little socialist
darling of the Democrat Party.
And we don't want it.
The district doesn't want it.
I don't think the
country wants it either.
See more and more people
waking up across the country
to these Democrat
Socialists of America.
- Does it strike you
as a very odd thing
that the progressives,
that they're for all of
this crazy gender stuff
and all of the race stuff
and all of these things
that, if you go to the
Bronx, I honestly cannot,
I've been to the Bronx a
million times in my life,
like, wandering down the street,
nobody would be for this stuff.
It's so disconnected-
- No, they don't.
- From what's on the street.
- That really pushed
them over the edge.
They don't want that
creepy, weird stuff
going on in the schools.
You know, American values need
to be taught in our schools.
We need God back in our schools.
We need God back in our country.
We have to get rid of
these woke policies.
Woke does not fix anything.
It does not fix inflation.
It does not fix the
education system.
It does not fix crime.
Woke is useless, just like AOC.
- (laughs) But tell me
how you really feel.
Are you getting any support
from whatever the Republican
machinery is in New York?
I know it's very kinda
outta whack over there,
although I have to
go on the record,
I think something good
is happening with Zeldin.
I honestly think there's
a chance. We'll see.
But is there any machinery
from the Republicans
that's helping you?
- No, it's me, my grassroots.
I have a very small team.
It's basically me and my GC
and a couple of volunteers
and that's really it.
I'm just doing a really
strong grassroots campaign.
I have no help from
any RNC, any PACs.
I was in a primary.
I forced a primary on New York.
I was the only one in New York
that was not backed by the
GOP and I won the primary
because I'm a fighter.
- Wow.
- I don't back down,
I stand my ground,
and I'll always be that way.
That's why I can tell you
that I will make
changes for District 14.
I will fight for everyone.
- So you were not backed by
the GOP, you win your primary,
and then did they call you
or did they just
ignore you after that?
Did they just think
- The Bronx GOP chairman-
- that this is a far gone
conclusion?
- Did call me.
The Bronx GOP
chairman called me.
He was very, you know,
he is working with me.
He's very nice to me.
And that's really it.
But at first, they did not.
They did not have my back.
- Interesting, interesting.
- But I forced
a primary on them.
- Yeah.
Is it odd that you're,
do you think that you're
not getting more attention?
I mean, when I reached
out to you on Twitter,
I was kinda like,
"Wait a minute."
I almost forgot that AOC
was up for reelection.
Everyone is right now.
- There's no talk-
- And then I was like,
- About her race.
- "Wait a minute, obviously,
I gotta get this
woman on the show."
- No one talks about her race.
No one talks about it.
And like I said, if
I didn't push for...
I had to petition twice.
So if I didn't push for a
primary, I wouldn't be here.
Their handpicked
guy would be here.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And to be quite honest with
you, and I'll call him out,
you have the Conservative
Party chairman,
Pat McManus in the Bronx,
who's left the Conservative guy
on the ticket to spite me.
You're not spiting me.
You're spiting the
people of the district.
Who are you taking votes from?
The people are not gonna
get the change they want.
If it's a very close race
and you leave somebody there
just because you think
you're spiting me,
you're not spiting me;
you're spiting the people.
- Yeah.
- So you don't belong
as the chairman.
- You mentioned
the policing before
and obviously AOCs hypocrisy
where she's wandering around
with armed guards while she's
calling to defund the police
and all that kind of stuff.
How, in the couple years
that she's been in Congress,
how has the security situation,
or the safety
situation I should say,
how has that changed
in the Bronx?
- It's horrible.
There's no more plain
clothes detectives.
There's no more
police on our subways.
They've lost their
qualified immunity.
They're cut all over, so
they're working double shifts.
It's sad.
Then the way they're
treated is a disgrace.
They're the real heroes.
Our first responders
are the real heroes,
our policemen, our
firemen, our EMT workers.
What they did to this state
and to the workers
is disgusting.
They go out and they want,
oh, they wanna praise
football players
for taking a knee to our flag.
Look, I have my American flag.
- Well, there you go.
- It's tattooed on me.
My dad's Marine
badge, tattooed on me.
My dad's Purple
Heart tattooed on me.
I have "Semper Fi" on my neck.
I love America.
I love this country.
I carried wounded warriors
on Spartan courses
before I got sick with COVID.
I carried them.
I also carried a
coffin with 22 dog tags
to raise awareness
to veteran suicide.
I love this country,
and it needs to go back
to real American values.
- So what is going on over there
that she even got elected
in the first place?
I mean, I get it that a lot
has gone wrong since then,
and then COVID and now the
wokeness is very obvious.
But how did it
even happen there?
- Well, Joe thought
he had it in the bag.
Joe Crowley, I think
that was his name.
He just didn't show up to his
debates and he wasn't in town,
basically the same
thing she's doing now.
He just forgot about the
district just like she did,
and now you see the
tides turning with her
that when she comes into the
district, she's booed out
and she never talks
about the district.
That's how she snuck in.
She got in, she made promises.
She didn't keep them.
She went in and says,
"Oh, I'm different.
I'm not the establishment."
No, yeah you are.
You are. You're worse
than the establishment.
She's worse.
She brought communism
into New York.
She brought socialism
- She is, I like that,
she's worse than
the establishment,
and she really is.
- Yes.
- You know, one of the things
that I've been saying
about her for a while is
she doesn't realize it,
but she's actually
the past of politics.
She thinks she's the
future of politics,
but I actually think
all of her divisive,
obviously I don't
like the ideas,
but even just the divisiveness
and the using groups
against each other,
that's not what the
future of this country is.
She's managed-
- That's right.
- She's done a trick on us.
I'll give her credit.
She became a star,
but that's it.
- That is it.
And she can't relate
to the district.
She claims she can. She can't.
She's not a mom.
She doesn't know what
it's like to have...
I'm a grandma too.
She doesn't know what it's like
to send a kid to
school with a mask on
and have all these mandates
and to have, you know, real
issues to worry about, money.
She's not like that now.
She goes to the Met Galas.
She drives her Tesla.
She has security around her.
She's living the
life of an elite,
and she left her
district behind,
the district she
promised to fight for.
- I'm guessing probably
because of some of those videos
of the protestors at her things,
she's probably not
spending a lot of time
at the home district
at this point, right?
She's just in DC all the time?
- No, she fled to California.
I don't know when
she's coming back.
But the chicken's out
there looking for her.
- (chuckles) I really wanna
know more about this chicken.
I love this chicken idea.
This is gonna become
like a real thing.
- Oh, it's on my page.
Go on to my congressional page.
You'll see the chicken.
- All right,
- He carries a sign-
- we'll grab the chicken.
- And everything.
We'll put some pictures
of this chicken.
I noticed on your Twitter
bio, you say "America First."
I'm curious, what does that-
- America First.
- What does that mean to you?
Because this is becoming
sort of the new trend
and you can feel a
little tension now
with the Republicans.
Are we America First or are we,
you know, sort of old
school Republicans,
whatever that means?
- I'm all
America First.
- Then you have all
the disaffected liberals
who are kind of coming over
now, you know, who are waking up
and going, "Okay,
something's not right."
What does that mean to you?
- We need term limits.
We need America First patriots
who put America first.
Americans should come first.
Look, in the district, we
just had a problem with the,
they sent their
illegal immigrants
to Orchard Beach in my district.
I'm not gonna lie.
I went to Orchard Beach on
October 1st and I protested.
Because of AOC's policies,
the open border policies
that she pushes for,
the sanctuary cities,
they decided to send
the illegal immigrants
and house them in Orchard Beach,
give them security, give them
food, give them heated tents.
We have homeless, we
have homeless veterans
in our district.
So I went to Orchard Beach
and I says, "No,
not in my backyard
and not in any backyard
they should be.
Send them back.
Send them back and let
them wait on line."
So I declared October
Adopt an Illegal Immigrant
Month in Orchard Beach.
Come on down, 81 million strong.
Take an illegal
immigrant home with you.
Feed them, call them,
give them shelter,
but get them the hell
out of the district.
- Wow.
- And I went...
You know, they started
coming, calling me racist.
I did three rallies, protest
rallies, back to back to back.
I didn't care.
I went out there and
I say it like it is.
You know, sometimes I'm
harsh, but I'm real.
Can't take that from me.
- So you didn't want to,
- And that's who moves.
- You didn't wanna bus 'em
straight up to Martha's
Vineyard instead?
- That's what I said.
I says, "Why don't they
go to Martha's Vineyard?"
Oh, I forgot they
were sent there.
50 of them were moved by the
National Guard the next day
and they were fed Cheerios
with people with rubber gloves.
They didn't even get a hot meal.
- So when they show up, you
said they're getting food,
they're getting security,
they're getting housing,
and then-
- They're gone now.
- And then I suspect, well,
for a while, the
Democrats in New York
were pushing to
have illegals vote.
So I don't even know where
that stands at this point
but you could kinda see-
- Yeah, no.
- What's going on here.
- That's not anymore.
That was shot down
by the courts.
And the illegal immigrants
are now out of Orchard Beach.
They did move them
to Randall Island
so I have to protest there.
Even though they're
not my district,
I still have to fight for it
'cause it's something
I believe in,
believe strongly about that.
They shouldn't be here at all.
We shouldn't be
housing them at all.
They need to go back
on line, go back.
Go shut the border.
- I got it, I got it.
I'm curious, what do you
think the chances for New York
to really turn
this thing around?
I told you right
before we started,
I'm born in Brooklyn, I
grew up in Long Island.
I did move to LA
about eight years ago,
but I'm in free Florida now.
You know, when you
hear Kathy Hochul say,
"If you don't share our
values, go to Florida,"
I mean, she's basically
talking directly to you.
She's talking to half the state.
But are you hopeful that
New York can turn it around?
'Cause it should
be a great state
and New York City
should be the city
that everybody wants to live in,
but it's not how it is now.
- It should be.
And I do believe that there
is going to be change.
I really feel good
about November 8th.
I do feel that a
lot of Republicans
are gonna be winning
on November 8th.
I think Lee Zeldin has a really
great shot at beating Kathy.
He really does.
And I really feel a lot of
momentum in the district.
I was endorsed by
Reverend Ruben Diaz
from the Latino community,
the Bangladeshi community,
"The Jewish Press."
I got all endorsements
by Democrats.
They're endorsing me.
They're embracing me.
They want freedom. I'm
fighting for freedom.
It's good verse evil.
It's freedom verse government.
Nobody wants that.
They're so out of
touch with Americans.
That's why I say,
"America first."
You're putting us last.
We belong first.
Even people that came
over here legally,
they came over for
the American dream.
We're all being
pushed to the side.
It's not right.
- Tina, you remind me
of every single one
of my friends' moms
growing up in Long Island.
I wish you a lot of luck.
And I really think-
- Thank you.
- There's a chance,
and as I keep saying
we just gotta get to a
point where in America,
we can look in that back mirror
and say, "AOC ya
later, enough of her."
So if people wanna support,
they wanna help you
out, where can they go?
- TinaForteForCongress.com.
TinaForteForCongress.com.
- Tina, I hope
we're swearing in.
- Thank you so
much for having me.
God bless you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.